You're really kind to say so.
I mean, Harry, Catherine and I really felt this was such an important area...
...that throughout all our charitable work, whether it's veterans, homelessness, addiction,...
...most of it seemed to stem back to mental health issues.
And you know, I read your open letter you wrote the other day...
...and I thought it was incredibly moving...
...and very brave of you to write down such personal feelings.
And I wanted to ask you very much what you, how you found speaking out and how it made you feel.
It made me very nervous at first.
For me, waking up every day and feeling sad...
...and going on stage is something that is very hard to describe.
There's a lot of shame attached to mental illness.
You feel like something's wrong with you...
...and in my life I go, "Oh my goodness,..."
"...look at all these beautiful, wonderful things that I have and I should be so happy..."
...but you can't help it if in the morning when you wake up,...
...you are so tired, you are so sad.
You are so full of anxiety and the shakes that you can barely think...
...but it was like saying, "This is a part of me and that's okay."
It's interesting to see and hear from you how much having that conversation...
...or having that sort of ability to speak to someone really made a difference to you.
I think, for me, the little bits that I've learned so far about mental health...
...is very much the case of, you know, it's okay to have this conversation.
It's really important to have this conversation and that you won't be judged.
It's so important to break open that fear and that taboo,...
...which is only gonna lead to more problems down the line.